you mean no one would dare stand up and
say like god you're not going to sing a
song every every right or not more of
your damn heart
[Music]
[Music]
but shove Rushton and his people are now
talking about a language called old
world and old world is the first
language ever spoken on this planet by
higher primates beyond old world there
is inarticulate silence an old world is
a thirty five thousand year old language
how can we know such things you have to
push into the linguistic literature and
you're a better man than I am Gunga Din
but there are websites you can go to
where people speak in old world and you
can hear what it sounded like and sounds
like a bunch of really primitive people
well but as I lay in the tubs at Esalen
a vast vocabulary of subtle gradients of
interpersonal states amongst longing
need rejection triumph and defeat are
passed in front of me and frankly I'd
rather read my manual and my hardness
but I must have not that I'm not proud
of the fact that the highest I can get
is to teach at Esalen I'm not at all
proud of the fact that that seems to be
where I talked out had I greater courage
I would go further but I don't I'm
hoping that you people my graduate
students as it were will sacrifice
yourselves on the pyre of going further
and and and report back the situation I
described with these octopi was coastal
shallow water
two pi so-called cert the literal octopi
but they have also evolved into the
deaths the so-called abyssal octopi that
exists below 1500 meters in the sea
where there is absolute darkness and to
carry their intention to communicate
into that darkness over the past seven
hundred million years they have evolved
phosphorescent organs and have covered
themselves with lights with eyelid like
membranes that can be rapidly blinked
and flickered so that when you descend
into the abyss you then see pure
linguistic intentionality among the
cephalopod yet because they have become
what we aim to become under the wise
leadership and stewardship of George
Bush namely a thousand points
if I had eight hands I could really get
gestural height a funny experience
involving octopi I know a woman I'm sure
she would not begrudge me this
description of her she is a very frank
exhibitionist I mean this is the woman
who at every party takes her clothes off
and dances on the tabletops and so far
she is an inveterate exhibitionist she's
totally frank about it and I had been to
the Monterey aquarium and seen the
octopus there they have a giant octopus
well most of the time this guy just
hunkers low and he's sort of off in a
corner one beady eye checking you out
but of course because octopi have this
mode of communication
they're very set up to respond to visual
display so this woman walked past this
time and this octopus practically leaped
into the air it came down out of the
tunnel it was pressing against the glass
it was beating against the glass and
what it was was one exhibitionist
recognizing another I mean it was just
clear across the species lines the power
of neurosis is no barrier
perhaps if someone said it sounds like
megalomania to me Martha
yeah well as bandwidth expands the web
is going to become much more of an
interactive and as you say virtual
environment and I'm learning all this
stuff this is where my heart is these
days I don't want to have to depend on
other people to implement things for me
and I've discovered learning the
software is like mental calisthenics I
mean you really do get buffed up
intellectually if you can run Rea dream
design
and render 3d objects and embed them in
VRML it's it's and it's a great way to
relate to your children okay they're
using three steps add one of the uses
suggested for nanotechnology somewhat
facetiously was that you could have
these little electronic mites that you
combed into your hair and every day they
would creep out to the end of each hair
measure its length and cut it off so
you'd have the permanent hair cut
maintained by nano mites from Clairol
now I will infuse the mysticism
and worse
magic